Now let's move on to
the Nil-Coalescing operator,
which is the double question mark.
This is a great operator that's
built on top of the optional type.
What it allows us to do is
safely unwrap an optional and
if it contains something,
we use the unwrap value.
But if it's nil, then we can
specify a different value to use.
So let's look at this line that
uses the nil-coalescing operator.
This is the way that
you want to read this.
I want to assign the value
of newFavoriteRestaurant
to the whereToEat constant.
But if newFavoriteRestaurant is nil,
then I want to use
the yummyRestaurant instead.
So right now the newFavoriteRestaurant
is assigned to Chez Fonfon.
So that's what gets
assigned to WhereToEat.
But if we make this nil instead,
then Chez Lulu gets used instead because
newFavoriteRestaurant is now nil so
it skips and uses the yummyRestaurant
instead and that's pretty slick.
Now below, I have a more complex example
that uses multiple nil coalescing
operators together.
I encourage you to check it out.